[Music]
all right guys uh what do you think of a
chick-fil-a owner what do you picture a
christian boy definitely a christian boy
a good christian boy yeah because to own
um chick-fil-a i think it's like within
the church connection and also yeah the
chicken at the church of chicken like
which church like a protestant oh there
you go yeah you're some kind of
christian related within the church and
also um
you have to work there for quite some
time yeah yeah i picture like um i don't
know like a dude with a gay kid head in
his arm
and just give it a bite
he was just being daunted oh my god
beating up gay kids
yeah it's like it's like a closet gay
person who's not allowed to admit
they're gay because of religion so
they're wearing a cow outfit instead
with a picket son that says eat more
chicken oh pretty good very specific wow
well um a chick-fil-a over in texas in
marshall texas is uh
under some scrutiny right now the owners
are being accused of witchcraft what
wait define witchcraft in 2022 that's a
very key thing right there i'm glad you
said that uh like one of those dolls
where you [ __ ] stab it and you hope
that someone just voodoo dolls
that's exactly what i picture when
someone says witchcraft i thought it was
like a old lady with the [ __ ]
cauldron and she's going
double double toil and trouble she's
throwing like a [ __ ] eye of newt yeah
you know
always
you know salamander
yeah yeah explodes a little bit why uh
what was witchcraft back in the day
was it just chicks burning incense like
real [ __ ] like some um druid [ __ ] like
people inventing great things and being
called witches right yeah yeah right
exactly you got a cauldron it's like i
was [ __ ] making soup yeah and they're
like you're a witch and they would set
them on fire afterwards i mean like why
is there i have nude in your soup
that's true here's the funny thing this
is the 2022 version of witchcraft i
guess so uh these owners of the
chick-fil-a are being accused of
witchcraft because
they posted a video of them when they
were building the chick-fil-a
burying a bible underneath the
foundation of it why would you bury a
bible is that christian it's the reverse
effect of uh ancient burial grounds to
bless the customers they left it open on
the book of joshua but isn't that weird
where you would bury it doesn't that
like represent like more of a disrespect
yeah so here's a picture of them uh
there it is
on the ground breaking and then is that
a is it an official thing that it's like
if you bury a bible that it's like
either satanic or witchcraft like that's
a new practice that's what's weird to me
is like even in seventh-day adventist uh
culture growing up you're not supposed
to do stuff like that you guys don't
bury bibles well you don't even put a
bible under another book like like i'm
not religious anymore but like to this
day i retain the same respect of like if
i'm stacking books i'll still put the
bible on top just out of reflex like
putting a bible on the dirt on the
ground and then like burying it is just
i guess it's perspective right because
these people are probably thinking oh
cool we could like always have it
preserve on this chapter forever and it
could shine [ __ ] light like i can
kind of see that cute idea i like it but
it doesn't matter what your intent is
you just defended a bunch of christians
actually you should [ __ ] apologize
hey you should apologize but i also see
how it's like yo i'ma bury this [ __ ]
[ __ ] right here
and get god angry because i want the
devil to come yeah it's like it's clear
what their intentions are but it's funny
to me because i'm wondering if this is a
sect of christianity where that's like a
i don't know like subterranean blessings
or everything because because it's very
opposite normally like you wouldn't even
put it be more like like
like planting a seed and then having the
energy of it grow into imagine just a
bro that sounds like witchcraft i like
that i guess so i play magic the other
i'm into it but isn't that such a funny
response like today like a christian
planning a bible is witchcraft you know
what that reminds me of you know in
ghostbusters you [ __ ] slide that [ __ ]
open and it goes and then [ __ ] sucks
the ghost box that like yeah the book of
joshua yeah oh maybe that's the thing
i bet you it's a chapter on prosperity
right they open that [ __ ] book right
and then they're trying to get all the
customers to come shop at [ __ ]
chick-fil-a i like it
yeah we should do that here we should
what would we bury under the jk office
portals because then all the guys will
come
leave it all in the on the book of
josh's big dick
get all the dudes we need a pornography
book to find in bear star named joshua
here's what they want to say about it
they said uh the owner said
while we do serve delicious food people
are what's most important to us our
purpose here is simple to glorify god by
being a faithful steward and make all
that trust
and get them 12 count nuts
oh chick-fil-a sauce yeah so they're i
mean they have honest uh earnest
intentions but
it is a little weird you know i say
carry on this practice let's continue
this how do you know there wasn't a
bible under every place you've ever
eaten that you don't know olive garden
what if that's what makes it taste good
put your bread sticks under there yeah
it might taste good because if you guys
have anything crazy buried in like your
backyards growing up no i think it's
stupid
i think it's dope when like a fish died
you would like bury it right thinking
that like you were doing something
proper and then like later your mom
would randomly be like what the [ __ ] is
this and there's just like all these
maggots and stuff and worms all over it
and you're like you obviously didn't
bury it six feet you better get like one
inch
it's it's
out yeah
you buried your pets in the backyard i
had i had a red hair slider that i um i
i buried i dug a hole
and i put it in there
and then i don't know i felt like i
didn't know if it was gonna decompose
and get absorbed
so i took the shovel like sharp ways
and it went like this you cut it in half
and then i heard the shell cracked and
then i was like then i felt really
really bad
why did you do that what i don't know
what are you shredder like how old are
you eight or nine that is way worse than
what ryan did are you just eight or nine
figures [ __ ] out you're like like a hole
and you kind of pat it flat you know and
you're like
i don't know maybe i should like what
was your turn
let me respect it now let me disrespect
you
let me chop it up into more pieces yeah
but strange ritual they have in there
barb was a weird kid i wonder what was
his [ __ ] friend
just cutting turtles in half oh let's go
around the table have any of you guys
cut a turtle in half we'll start with
you steve yeah no i have not we don't
know if it was perfectly in half because
it was under the ground so let's not
assume fractions i remember i buried
live frogs so i think i'm pretty [ __ ]
up too
live frogs
why were they alive
just when you think it couldn't get
worse it comes joe hot and heavy please
nobody double down on top of that
frog i was like six two i don't know you
were sixteen dude my cousin taught me
when it rained this was like oh [ __ ] and
then he's like where's the scissors and
i'm like why are you so excited he goes
you got to come with me he grabbed the
scissors he pulled my hand right we went
outside and there's hella [ __ ] snails
and he comes up and he makes me cut the
eyes of the snails every single one
and he's dying laughing he's [ __ ]
laughing dude and i'm just like
as soon as the snail eye goes up he goes
and he cuts that tree oh my god you know
my neighbor of course i was like four i
was like four years old
my neighbor across the street how does
he already have this tradition for you
know the [ __ ] soup base from
shenanigan like the non-chip noodles uh
when it would rain and the snails would
come out you would come and open the
soup base and sprinkle it on the [ __ ]
snails and [ __ ] too and just starts
foaming damn and you got like have you
seen your cousin lately got a kick out
of it yeah he's got two kids
he's a very nice man was he pulled up on
a [ __ ] dolly
good to see you joe don't [ __ ] with cats
bro don't [ __ ] with cats it's been a
long time since you visited
i too have fathered children
i do
can you bring back the scissors for all
time
can we like focus on that sentence of
like oh it's raining get the [ __ ]
scissors he grabs your hand and pulls
you
laughing the whole time yeah that's
that's happened a lot right i think he's
like 10 years older than me so he was
like 15.
so i was like five or so i don't know
cutting the eyes off of snails this was
like oh yeah buried live frogs please
don't double down oh yeah so uh
why did you bury the livestock yeah we
didn't get to the bottom we used to
catch tadpoles and frogs and then um
i don't know there was a lot of dust
there so i threw it on top and then they
were jumping and you know how like dust
sticks onto the frog yeah i thought that
was pretty funny right so then i grabbed
a bunch of dirt and then i threw a frog
in there and i covered it to see if you
could crawl out okay yeah and then it
kind of you slowly saw the dust and i
was like oh [ __ ] it could come out right
and then i grabbed that [ __ ] again and
i dug it even deeper and i threw it in
and i covered it and then it wouldn't
come out i was just having the worst day
of his life
he's like how the [ __ ] would i keep
ending up on the ground this poor
[ __ ] frog yeah it would come out
and then my friend starts stomping on it
so then i start stopping on it and we're
like stomping on this this thing
and bart comes in with a shovel
you know when you're kids right you just
you're just [ __ ] stupid like you're
just both laughing and stopping and then
yeah but then i did learn my lesson i
did learn my lesson though
this little girl with this
it was with their church group she she
saw it she ran and her dad's a pastor
she told [ __ ] her dad on us and he
came over and he goes what are you guys
doing and i was like oh we had some
frogs and she goes yeah daddy he got the
frogs they threw it they covered it and
they started stopping on it and then she
was all crying and [ __ ] and we didn't
know what was going on and he's all like
you guys gotta try to keep them alive
and we're just trying to like find them
i can't even find them because it's like
we dug them so [ __ ] deep like digging
in the wrong spot it's over here
and then apple was so sad and angry
right and then me and my friend were
like looking at each other like
damn dude did we [ __ ] just make god
angry like what did we do because he was
like that's that's god's creation oh you
made the devil [ __ ] happy yeah yeah
another sacrifice to molly god was not
watching he was like i ain't part of
this [ __ ] yeah we were just i was just
like [ __ ] i [ __ ] up man i don't know
what i did but i think i [ __ ] up
so i don't go to church
see that's why i don't like religion
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you